歡迎收看趙華 我是趙華
我是艾倫 艾倫回來了
終於回來了
你知不知道現在出了多少亂子
你是說是台灣股市嗎
都很多啊 就是到底什麼樣的情況
像你半夜四點會爬起來呢
你是說煮牛肉麵這件事情嗎
我只有連準會說可能要升息的時候
我可能會跳起來
等一下半夜四點對我們財經人來說
是很重要的時間點
對 基本上就是要嘛公布牌或財報嘛
對不對 要嘛就臨時會
記者會講完了嘛 對不對
不然就是突然飛彈要射出來了嘛
大概就這樣
因為呢 半夜四點我也有可能
如果看到一些事情會傳遜給你
就是每一股那時候收牌啊
對 如果發生嚴重的大事情的話
我們確實會起來上廁所的時候
稍微看一下牌面
不過呢 台股反彈到這個地方
我們這幾天是有點開始出現
那些橫盤整理
甚至有一點點小回落
這個是所謂要打腳嗎
這個問題非常好
我們等一下用技術面向來看一下
好 但是到底為什麼事情就是這樣
在反彈的時候因為彈得很急
你不在的那一個禮拜彈得很急
那就會覺得
好像就一路不回頭了
可是就會永遠發生一些事情
讓這個彈稍微停住一下
那停住的同時
我們到底往下走
要樂觀看還是要謹慎看
還是我就繼續放假
對
key point在你啊
我們來看一下
看一下為什麼昨天
其實昨天台子夜盤
我想說不錯
長得快400點
請來看1.60點
然後看一下
又是美伊的關係
所以現在美伊關係
還是會稍微影響到
美國的股市走勢
對 那尤其是可能
反彈到這個階段
大家又覺得
有一些比較敏感的狀態
還出現 我覺得找到這裡
就大家又要開始找一個理由
說要不要休息一下
事情有那麼簡單嗎
是的 沒有錯
我們來看一下
這個六十天的和平談判期
快要已經屆滿了
那雙方是沒有達成協議的
反而分歧是更深
所以大家就覺得說
因為這個美醫是不是又無果了
那無果呢
就推動油價去做上漲
那主要還有一個原因
就是河母之海峽呢
基本上都
就運量不是很好
所以看起來還是有在封鎖的
那這些原因呢
就油價會上漲
有叫上漲 剛好沒在直率也上漲
這個時候誰叫他下跌
股價叫他下跌
對 所以目前來說
這件事情影響到短線上的
一些股市上的總市
但其實昨天每股的半導體
是很強的
對 這個費半是漲了1.6%左右
那其他三指數是回落
什麼記憶體那一類還是很強
當然今天台灣股市
因為韓國昨天沒開盤
那間韓國開盤了
開盤早上漲3%很厲害
一看奇怪怎麼變跌的
台灣股市也變跌的
所以有一些壓力
那目前來說
這件事情就是恆母之海峽
到底該怎麼辦
那坦不懂
坦不懂就震盪囉
這兩個
這兩國走得很前面
他已經暗示你一件事了
要和平分手是不可能的
現在也是
三月就開始講了
我們財經也是有男女主角在鬧的
對啊
OK
原來是這樣
今年三月就開始了
不過我們上禮拜
臺灣補是很強
嘿嘿 對這很強呢
你可以發現新台幣也很強
是 我們從高到低
這反彈的幅度大概是0.7塊
會議途計的反過來看
七角 不要以股價漲這樣就完蛋了
沒有 沒有 這個是好事
這個是升值才會漲這樣
沒錯 所以你可以發現
我們那一波七月的這行情
其實籌碼是真的也有滿大的狀況
因為我們一路的慢慢的是緩貶的
那不過最近美元指數
是比較疲軟的
所以我們新台幣也拉得很不錯
那當然今天就有出現了一個
直漲迴貶的狀態了
所以要稍微注意一下
因為外資也是結束連六賣
所以是有相關的
這裡
今天賣了110求一
應該說結束連六買
連六買不好意思
因為8月以來真的是蠻積極在買的
難得看到
跟台幣非常的緊密結合
但只要台幣不升
那外資可能就先停
或是外資停了
台幣就不升了
沒錯
所以目前看起來
但我覺得也不錯啦
就至少我們有升的快一塊
那臺灣股市才有7000點的行情
好 那再來我們繼續看一下
所以從來我覺得
稍微震盪一下應該也可以
那再來呢
近期還是有一個主角非常不錯
就是細光子
細光子
而且他可能圍繞在世界的融資大哥
現在是揮打的身上
沒有錯 AI融資中心
所以呢
我覺得CPO後續還是要持續關注
那當然就那幾個族群
應該大家都沒買過
應該也都知道有拿幾隻了
他不要買了是不是
我們來看一下灰達宣布
這一個他的細光子交換機
要正式量產了
CPU會正式邁入大規模的商用
這個就是從實驗到驗證
到現在是要商用化了
那這個大家就自己看一下
重點在這裡
大家自己看一下
對嘛
重點是最近都在聊的是
真的有所謂的光通訊的需求缺口
沒錯 一路缺喔
訂單已經開始往後排
沒錯 排到2027年
那預期會延續到2028年
所以還有兩年的時間
那對啦 兩年半啦
那當然股價會提前發酵
再來台灣供應鏈
其實他就有宣布幾家公司
對 因為他宣布11家
那裡面台廠有4家
那當然這個外溢出來的
很多族群各股
當然還是可以去探討一下
台積電 紅海
月光旗下的細品還有波羅威
那這些就是從2025年以來
這個揮打的注資計畫
因為之前當然也有研調機構
就講到揮打這樣
全世界借錢變成世界債主
是對他不好的
是
可是事實上我覺得
這是一個滿偉大的計畫
沒錯
對 如果這些他投資的公司
能夠陸續的
因為他的助資
而在新創的發展上面
對 轉虧為營的話
他就會有所謂AI新活種的加入
而且不是燒錢的新活種
所以我覺得這樣的佈局
是非常有意義
這是一盤大局
這個局可能要好幾年
這個事業要非常的廣
好 那我們來看事業
目前比較短一點的
就是近期走勢
我們現在小局
對對對
近期走勢
我們台灣股市
今天跌了548點
是近期的一個
相對比較大的跌點
而且在露營的同時
可能夜盤也是比較微弱的
對 跌250點左右
那我們來看一下
大盤一路從這個3904左右
一路反彈到4600
所以反彈了7000點
那短短幾天
兩週的時間
所以有沒有一個短線
長多的疑慮
我認為是有的
但是這個疑慮
就會是說這邊彈完了
要準備要直接這樣再下來的話
其實我覺得不會啦
要給大家一點信心
我覺得是不會啦
所以這一波返台的過程中
我們很多跟著降槓槓啊
這個去估值啊
不不不不大家其實心情啊
還沒有回復
那回復到現在呢
其實大家就可以陸續去注意了
回落過程中
有沒有新的買進的集會
剛要回復
他就直接又給你
就是彈枕求證
你可能受傷兩次嘛
那接下來這一次就不要錯過
這一次就不要錯過
但是也不是說講話好樂觀
明天有疊就去買
我們給大家一些比較技術面上的應用
我們這邊一路沿著誰去墊稿
沿著五綠軍線
所以其實是蠻強的走勢
不過今天滿確定的是五綠軍線是疊破了
五綠軍線疊破就要注意
這一波可能就要稍微休息震盪一下
震盪過程中我們去觀察幾個支撐區
當然軍線這邊全部都是支撐
十日軍二十日軍
季線都是支撐
那目前我會比較看的是月線跟季線
如果這邊能夠出現黃金交叉
我覺得走勢未來應該非常可以期待
那另外一個這是軍線給的
再來就是KBUN給的
這一根大量就是這一根紅K
那這個紅K的高低點都可以視為短支撐
所以這邊大概是4萬5000點
跟這裡大概是4萬4到4萬3800左右
所以來到這個區間
我們先看4萬5000點的附近
能不能有一個這個漂亮的下影線
或者是說開低走高的大紅K
那如果有 我覺得就視為止跌
那相對的 如果沒有就直接可能
我們可能不小心就直接跌破了
那我們就回來看這個地方
然後再看有沒有出現這樣子的訊號
我都能視為這邊應該都會是一個新的好買點
所以這邊我們稍微注意一下
讓他震盪一下短線漲多
那漲多的過程中
找一些止跌的訊號
就有機會是新的進場機會
好 再來另外一個就是貴買
貴買呢 這一波反彈呢
其實這一波反彈幅度也不輕
可是因為他前面疊疊也比較重
目前來說我們注意的是
他來到季線兩天沒有過
沒有過
他今天整理的幅度也比較大
我們大盤手石律軍
但櫃馬是連石律軍一行疊破了
所以今天周小谷的體感
是比較差一點點
比較差一點點
尤其這個上升趨勢
都一級頭被破壞掉
所以我覺得櫃馬這邊
也稍微注意一下
這一個平台的位置
能不能回測完之後
也做一些防守
然後再看有沒有機會來一個N字型的走勢去墊高
這裡就有機會是主勝段
所以我們先等指碟
然後好的訊號出現
譬如說他指碟就算了
還一口氣站回全部均線
那我覺得這個要過高的機會就很大
所以目前來說大家可以這兩天去觀察一下
尤其明天要臺紙期 月結算
那結算完之後
那有沒有一個新的脈絡可以去延續下一個月
那我覺得都是可以好好注意的
等於你們在看技術形態的時候
這邊來做一些整理
反而是一個比較好的
所以對頭朋友也是
因為你說你是神人嗎
可以做到這麼一大段
那很少的人
是
可是如果證明基本面
那些測試過沒有問題
那整理一下
再上就是剛剛艾倫講的主聲段
可能反而會展開
對啊 所以我覺得
你說會打第二隻腳嗎
我覺得概率偏低
你為什麼每次都要畫那麼兇
沒有嘛 因為概率偏低
他也有可能一個狀況
就是長短腳
是
長短腳
不是長這樣嗎
對啊 所以我覺得不用
有回落應該是可以站在一個
開心的狀態
那我們到台積電
台積電目前也蠻明確的
就一個區間震盪
2,300到2,450
所以等這個高點去做突破
應該就是心動能的展開
那在台牙電
我們原本一直畫的越線
向上趨勢線
在最近上禮拜也做突破了
那不過跟上櫃一樣有點類似
就是都來到季線挑戰兩天
都有一些賣壓被賣下來了
那目前上升趨勢還在
那以台大電來講
現在800伏原本說延後出貨
那現在已經要陸續出貨了
所以我覺得未來基本面應該會
反映在股價身上
那來到這個地方
我覺得台大電有點委屈
所以長先來講
台大電現在這個狀態
應該是可以縫低去陸續做佈局的
可以拿一點信心
好 等於雙台
台光電是創歷史新高
看到台光電創歷史新高
台積電是一個穩盤要角
而台大電視是一個有點委屈的
其實我們的三台還是蠻厲害的
所以在剛剛的大前提一下
因為這段時間只要下修
我們對於基本面產業面
都降得非常清晰了
而現在排面上
偶爾會有一些亂流
流氯一戰
它不是一個新的消息
可是它造成了一些
在技術現行上的回檔
這回檔目前都是健康的
就等著剛剛艾倫講的
回檔修正之後
如果外資又回頭
那主聲段可能就會展開
所以趕快回來來告訴你
到底我們看好哪一些的產業
尤其像PCB
他們在半年報上面的成績非常好
未來產業掌望也很高
下半段來幫您做分享了
好 我們來分享
最近還是有一個族群
非常的深猛
是
火海鮮
有創歷史新高的都蠻深猛的
是的
這個我們今天講的是
已經成型的ABF
是
因為其實更生猛的
我覺得是材料
喔
對對對
沒有啦 就是PCB最上游啦
中游那一類 CC游那一類
不過我們今天來講一下ABF
這個我們上次我還記憶猶存
怎麼樣
那個誰
婉庭經理
是 總經理
喔 總經理 不好意思
加個總
不好意思 不好意思
有來說嘛
他們有看好明年是風莊年嘛
是
那確實目前看起來
陸續有一些新聞出來就是
這一些三大廠
緊縮心機難練
未來的ABF的比例會拉更高
然後BT的比例會趨近於0
對 所以目前看起來
ABF的缺貨狀況應該是
非常非常明確的
那這個當然就是前四家
台灣可能以跟ABF比較明確的
不過我們今天要講的是這三家
我們剛剛有提到
有一些外溢的效應
對 像今天星星
總算穿一個歷史新高了
新興創歷史新高
對 因為南電跟景碩
在前面那個古災之前
就已經創歷史新高
不知道在哪裡去
所以我們剩下輪六啊 現在
對 以新興的角度來講
他就是在南電這個位置
對 那南電這一波拉很兇嘛
那個時候新興一下發災啊
一下要幹嘛呢
古嘉就卡在那邊
其實之前都有分享過
新興這個有過高了
好 蘿蟻7月21號來看
那時候新興其實相較之下
就是比較便宜的
我們一直講說他是第一大廠
應該要跟上
結果這一波反彈
他倒是率先創歷史新高
對 幫他拍手
沒錯
這個星星
不負重望星星
終於啦
但也因為他這個前高都比較低
因為景碩
什麼前高比較低
景碩有創高
景碩這個星星沒高嘛
所以有創高
南電這裡也有創高
那我們來看一下
要跟大家講的是後面這幾位
這個金像電
因為延續剛剛的例子
對不對
曾經落後的現在都漲回來了
這個也是扶弱後搭
是啊
金像電你看
他現在才要挑戰季線
法蘭姑高在這
有一點
而且他這波疊的其實
很重
他這個是7月嘛
人家6月中就開始
6月就開始疊了
0疊
對0疊
那後面也撐不住
那目前來說
EPS看31到38塊
目標價有喊到1700的天價
因為PCB的本益比
會給得稍微
比較樂觀一點點
那不管怎麼樣
金像電現在的股價來講
我個人認為就是稍微委屈一點點
那以剛剛我們看景碩星際難電
他們都是在這個附近
或者是已經突破這個高點了
那你回來看金像電
這個機器是真的有在低
那下漾趨勢線也做突破了
沿著越線前面就做突破了
那今天盤中有漲停
不過大盤不太好
所以有被壓抑一點點
但也是漲6%
那漲6%也做了這一個小平台的突破
那蠻明確的
這裡應該是一個N字型的確立了
所以接下來季線只要站上
基本上就是全部軍線站回來
然後N字型的一個多方結構去向上做延伸
今天也有出一點量
所以我覺得呢
應該都可以好好注意一下
假設你緊縮信心難電
第一選擇一定是他們
但是如果你覺得現在他們有點貴
那我覺得落後補漲的應該都有一些機會
這個是經向電的部分
好這也是非常多網友在問的
營收的數字都開得非常漂亮
是
那可是股價卻腰斬
前面一陣子是腰斬
再來看到的就是滑通
哇 這個
他的線怎麼啦
他要怎麼躺著橫線啊
哇 這個線畫得好直啊
滑通其實在今年上半年
可能還在100塊
那一路有漲到300多塊
其實他們漲幅也已經非常兇了
那最近又回到這個地方
其實股價也一度來到154塊
也是接近腰斬
那腰斬到過程中
大家前面注意
大家一起漲的時候
他有跟著拉
但是這一波大盤
上週開始在進去創高的時候
華通就沒有跟上了
他沒有跟上
我們這邊就可以稍微注意一下
跟金像電視一樣的邏輯
就是這基本面也OK
然後有各自的題材
就是低軌衛星等等的
量產等等的
那接下來如果要做一個
資金的輪動
會不會高階的
股價已經偏高了
在上面做震盪
然後資金往外溢到一些
低位階的族群
所以我現在有的人在看這樣子
就是找一些低位階來做
那華通目前來說
我們可以注意到這裡拉上來
在這邊做震盪
然後都是亮梭
今天也亮梭
今天其實大盤長500
跌500點嘛
他沒有跌
好 他很奇妙
他守在他的現增加
做橫盤整理
我也不懂
就是他是怕上去會有人
認現增加
馬上要賣掉嗎
還是怎麼樣
感覺床房控得不錯
我只能這樣說
因為上禮拜長他也沒長
這禮拜跌呢
他也不跌
就是在這邊震
所以我覺得他就是等一個
發動的契機
那只要這個平台低點都有守好
那就是看啊
時候會帶量突然像這樣子
突然出一個亮烘K拉出去
那基本上應該行情就會有一個新的走勢
可以去推伸
那目前來說
我覺得進場的停順點非常好抓
要嘛平台做跌破
要嘛你覺得基本面真的很好
那我手前提可是前提可能有點遠
所以可以大家看自己的
操作的邏輯去做停順的佈局
那佈局完之後就等發酵了
因為我覺得接下來大盤
要進入正當過程
應該還是會有族群出來做表現
對 因為可能就是懸鼓不懸翅
那開始找一些低位接又基本面不錯的
那或許後面會有一些機會
再來看就是見頂
好公司
其實他這波談有算是有像樣談
是的 那個時候他就是率先去反映
外溢的訂單的
對 連續兩根漲停單
是的 那來到這個地方
也出現了一個比較型態
他比那個金像墊跟華通來得強
因為他這邊是站上季線的
華通跟金像店都是準備挑戰極限
所以形態來講
見頂稍微比較強
但相對的就是他可能這裡也長得比較多一點點
那多一點點可以注意到這裡出現了一個高檔爆大量
所以這裡就會是一個觀察的壓力區
如果這邊能夠做突破
那這個行情應該就是換手成功準備挑戰前高
再來另外一個
他這邊高檔爆大量之後
股價也沒有直接向下中挫
而是守住這個缺口的高點位置在這邊做橫盤震盪
所以我覺得他整理方式應該也偏強
那剩下的就是看
什麼時候來一個更明確的換手
再去做一個N字型的突破去追價
那或者說不然就疊深一點
疊深一點
那看有沒有一些
又是一些價值的地方出現
再來重新去做介入
所以這三個都會是PCB
剛剛就是
因為其實大家比較鎖定的還是ABF
或者是材料
對
那反而是中間這些HDI
或者說BT系列
或者說其他的
伺服器板材
沒錯
都是大家沒有這麼著墨
其實還有很多 什麼男子店啊
電影頭控啊 高級啊
他們的位階都蠻低的
但是就沒有量
沒有量那就沒有價嘛
那目前來說有一些相關的
可能更機油一點
或者說比較紮實一點的
開始在陸續做一些小反應
那我覺得是可以去注意一下
有沒有落後補償的機會
因為這組織很大
很大
那現在竟然載板類
ABF類的已經往上衝了
它就開始陸續帶動
可能跟AI的社會程度
一定程度的落差
我覺得是這樣
但是如果等量能回來
或是像剛剛我們形容的
台幣如果繼續做一個
升值外資營運回來的話
那整體PTP
其實在角出的產業獲利
上面是非常好的
是的
那同樣的
如果需要今天節目
所有的圖卡資料
歡迎訂閱一下我們的
趙華艾倫說
目前是三萬YouTuber
不是百萬YouTuber
還需要大家的幫忙
好
所以搜尋一下
我們今天資料圖卡很精彩
因為等一下我們會有一位
大概一劑來一次的大來賓
上次已經扎扎實實
幫我們上了一課了
接下來我們剛已經偷看到他的資料了
他非常多的事情佐證
例如說現在AI不但是投資
還有收穫之外
我們內資的投資
也是一個很厲害 很驚人的
二零二七年
會是台股非常扎實 很棒的一年
等一下來聽聽看大來賓怎麼說
歡迎回來召華
我們今天的大來賓
是讓我覺得
在整個證宣業
這樣會不會得罪人
我覺得最有型的董事長
是
OK 這個
有 這個有緣起來
就是他每次來
都會帶來滿滿的資料
跟未來的展望
所以我們今天
就真的話不多說
因為他今天準備的資料量
多的喔
讓我們覺得一定要
在這個時候
我們要做一個
讓我們覺得一定要讓他好好的講清楚來
時間多留給他
好 今天來的是富邦投顧的董事長陳一光 光哥
召好愛倫 各位觀眾大家好
真的又請到你了
因為上一次你來是睽違了非常非常久
我們現在有進步了
我們現在隔了一季光哥
他們知道我們一個禮拜一次
我每次來你節目壓力很大
因為那個資料要準備滿久
不會 因為富邦投顧在光哥的帶領下
也有自己的節目
現在的訂閱量也很高
想要看光哥也可以優先到
富邦頭顧的YouTuber頻道
一定要的啊 要抽50萬訂閱了喔
那光哥今天有帶來做用名
股市沒有算命 只有算力
這邊講說沒有神準
只有看得比別人早
我有幫你濃縮
沒有馬後炮啦 只有早知道
這樣要算
他們要算口
所以這邊的話
光哥最近在看的
台股整個產業濃縮起來的金句
對 我覺得要看長線
看趨勢 然後看基本面
不要追逐市場上的這種宣鬧
然後把握時代的浪潮
我覺得目前看起來
還是以長線的產業面
基本面 總經面
來看整個股市投資
我覺得會是比較正確的方向
不過上一次光哥來市場
是一片歡欣鼓舞
但中間我們歷經的下殺
但是雜音都是類似的
一項一樣的新聞在當時
可能是很開心
中間下殺變成利空
那現在又來了
回答要幫所謂的OpenAI繼續注資
他希望這個AI的擁動已經能持續
但是一樣回到同樣的討論
當回答成為全世界的AI融資中心的話
我們的機會跟風險在那邊
我們從源頭來看
到底有沒有bubble
這個我覺得
假設你確定他沒有bubble
你後面任何的回檔
其實都是一個買點
那我們從這張表可以看出來
其實2025年這個綠色這一塊
我們叫賣產值的
我們把市家賣產就灰達啦
Intel AMD還有加台積電加起來
它Cache Infrault
從13304億到3777
那買產值的這些CSP大廠
從2045億直接灌到今年
可能會負的現金流
我覺得第一個我覺得
這個必須要留意就是它的現金流
我們要持續觀察它的財報裡面
所展現出來的現金流到底會不會
第二個就是從他的這部分的一個
資本支付計畫
贏收站他資本支付計畫比
你去看一下去年跟今年的這個
整個資本支付計畫是九成
跟將近40%明年
那一般來講
他的這個贏收站他資本支付計畫
是40%到50%
太高了
等於說他基本上是用
CAPEX去買他的贏收
這個是我們比較擔心的
那我們覺得過去平均
差不多是20%而已
那現在來到40%到50%
就是代表他的資本主義計畫太多
然後營收根本就更不上來
所以我們去抓了一下
他的這個平均若是以30%來看
他明年的
2030年的整個資本主義計畫到
兩兆美金
兩兆美金的話
你用30%的這個密度去算的話
其實他要抓6.6兆
可是你去看整個這個K格來算的話
CSP大廠他的這個負荷成長率
差不多是34%來看
他到2030年的營收只有5.5兆
第二個疑慮就是
假設它的營收站它的Kapex在三成左右
它至少要做到6.6兆營收
才有辦法不可以1分
這個是第二個我們看到的疑慮
剛剛前面那一張提到的就是說
它的Cache Outflow
這個是比較擔心的
然後這一塊第二個就是它營收站它的Kapex比
反推回來的營收到底要多少才有辦法
達到它的這個損益平衡點
所以我們就去算一下它的情境式分析
我們這邊有一個比較
這個叫做雄式的這個
這個數字跟基本還有牛市的這個數字
就是我們把
Apple's就是Average Revenue User的
這部分的一個單位
年的付費的這部分是150塊錢
150塊錢去估的話
其實他要2.8億
才有辦法達到水利量平
那你去看OpenAI現在的訂閱數差不多
他現在的這個活用
就是活用的這部分的一個
訂閱差不多10億
真正付費只有6到7%
等於是6000到7000萬
6萬7萬你現在要到2.8億的人
等於說你從今年到明年
你至少要增加
今年下半年可能要增加到5000萬
明年要到1億的這樣的訂閱人數
明年才有辦法來到損一兩平
那OpenRG對20
就是2030年這部分的一個
Target revenue來看是2800億
但是你如果這樣來算的話
其實它是有機會
在未來的2027年年底
是有機會 break even
因為如果是以這個2.8億的
這樣的一個算法來看的話
其實是有機會
所以目前看起來我們覺得
這個 bubble 應該
要破掉的機會比較不大
只是你必須持續觀察
我剛剛前面兩項
第一個 他的現金流
到底會不會持續轉負
然後什麼時候會轉正
這第一個
第二個就是他的營收
佔他的資本支付計畫比
那對照他的營收部分
是否能夠跟得上來
然後再加上
你要持續觀察他的訂閱數
因為你現在還是要回歸後來
到底他有沒有辦法把買產值的這部分的一個資金
變現成他的這個現金流跟他的獲利數值
這個是我們看到
目前看起來我們給的結論是覺得
不會有這種巴勃破裂的情況
但是要持續去觀察每一季
他的現金流跟他的這個訂閱數
那光哥我有個問題想要問你
是
就是我們現在在討論的是
CSP大廠的資本支出泡沫這件事情
那泡沫破掉會真的比較嚴重
還是說他資本支出降下來
但是上游賣產值的人
反而營收降下來會比較嚴重
其實這個就變成說他一個順序
就是說我們這一次假設看到
他們大幅增加資本支付計畫
導致七月份的股災
因為大家覺得說
你不斷地這個超過
對 你花太多錢
你沒有辦法回收
那我覺得這部分可能就會回到
這個賣產值
他到可能到2020 2030年
這時候可能會來一個停止
我覺得那時候可能就會反過來
可能就是CSP大廠
或是這些大原模形廠
它的獲利數字反而是比較好
這個我覺得
可能那個轉折點會是在
2020、8、29的時間點
對
所以反而是在投資邏輯上面
那時候再來做一些轉換
而且我們如果有用所謂的
Chill GPT
它也有在進步
所以如果是明年的話
後年它會轉虧為營
好像也是一個可以接受的時間點
那如果是以剛剛我提到
就是說艾倫所問到的問題
就是說那到底我們怎麼去看
它這個bubble這個時間軸
其實我這張表就是
就是我們剛剛公佈完半年報
其實那個數字應該非常非常好
對
其實是令人非常驚豔的一個數字
那我們應該富邦投顧的是
所有市場上裡面
孤今年數字其實是最貼近的
因為我們原先孤今年整個是6.89兆
我記得我們那個
我們在在對外公佈的時候
大家還覺得說太樂觀
因為去年只有4.51兆
可是今年公佈出來的上半年
就3.6兆
3.68兆這樣數字
其實你上下半年都是1比1的話
其實今年很容易突破7兆以上
所以你去看一下
這樣子的一個獲利數字
我們可以從今年挑戰7.5兆
這樣一個數字上來看的話
這是第二季2.08剛剛公佈出來的
然後第三第四季目前看起來
應該都可以維持兩兆以上
那你要主要看右邊
是這個部分的P乘Q的部分
我覺得第二季主要是
因為P的部分大幅的上揚
因為你P乘Q就是承德的
就是你的Price
乘以你的數量的部分
那你去看一下
這一次的這個獲利戰比
當然是千億至成方決的部分
將近40%
然後成熟日程是2%
可是你看記憶體
記憶體在這一塊
它的這個漲幅其實是非常非常大的
50到60塊
這個是其實如果是
百分比QQ 55到60%
那你到第三季第四季
其實它的這部分的QQ是有下滑
等於說你這部分的獲利數字
可能就沒有辦法
向它的這個報價來的漲了這麼多
但是還是可以維持毛利率
像這個Gosma Gens'這個記憶體有到80%
其實沒有問題 就是可以維持
只是說你的報價可能會
這個鬼故事就會出來
就是說因為你這個QQ
沒有像第二季來得這麼強
你看第二季漲最多的
第一個是記憶體
第二個是CCL
然後MLCC它是最整齊的
所以MLCC它在接下來下半年的
這部分的一個報價的漲幅來看
還是會持續
所以目前看起來賣產值的部分
在整個獲利數字的角度上來看
其實應該是賺得撥滿噴門
第三季這邊沒有數字對不對
但看得出來柱狀體是往下的
所以這已經反映在前一陣子的修正
還是我們要注意在第三季
就像您剛剛講到的
鬼故事出來
還有可能讓鯰谷再一波修正
我想趙豪問到關鍵重點就是
第二季他有一個
匯率上面的點子
所以他有匯對的這部分
毛利率的提升這第一個
第二個就是第二季的這部分
報價其實漲的是比較多
所以第三季他公布出來的數字
可能在兩兆上下
就沒有辦法像第二季來這麼好
因為第二季從1.57跳到2.08
那這個是一次性上來
那接下來我覺得
只要能夠維持兩兆多
其實就非常非常好
因為以七連五兆
你換算成配套Rexio
明年配個七成
其實明年配到五兆的現金股息
跟股票股利的機會其實滿大
其實這個我覺得是可以繼續做觀察
是 但是第四季可能就可以超越第二季
超越第二季
應該是沒有太陽懸念
因為目前看起來
從這個大廠這部分
給出的Galaxy
還有第四季基本上就是
2027年的這個前哨戰
台位的所謂的本夢筆
但那時候
我覺得會編製一個
比較好的一個Outlook
所以第四季應該會比
第二季來得高
因為我們都知道
股價是先行指標
所以台北講說
第三季這個情況
搞不好前陣子已經反映過了
那現在進入到第三季
而且是第三季的下半場囉
第四季甚至看明年
那光哥最注意的哪一些利機
是會支撐股價的
對 我想這個
我們為什麼來這個節目
每次都覺得壓力很大的原因是
其實我們要
做數比較不一樣的地方
其實我們剛剛從一開始的邏輯
從他的 Cash Flow 到那個
營收站他 K-Back Sp.
我想這是我們自己看到
就是說未來怎麼去觀察他 Bubble
然後第二個就是我們再看整個
他這部分的這個資本支付計畫
我們這樣看
資本支付計畫領先營收
贏收領先獲利
獲利帶動股價
所以當你看到
剛剛艾倫所問到
假設我資本支付計畫減少的話
我是不是股價就會下來了
沒有錯
所以目前看起來
國內的資本支付計畫
其實非常非常強
去看我們在2025年的時候
我們的資本支付計畫是1.03兆
那我們今年到1到5月
就4959億
也如果是把它處於五再乘以12的話
今年應該是1.2兆
1.2兆的KAPEX
就是它
Fundracing這麼多錢
它就是它從市場上募這麼多錢
它所拿出來的陳數效果是3到5倍
3到5倍 1.2兆乘以3到5倍的話
它應該會有3.6兆兆
將近6兆的這樣的營收創造出來
就像你剛剛我們一開始在
錄影之前所提到的這個普發現金
其實它是會有陳數效果
所以它這個Foundation下去之後
它所後面創造出來的
1到3年的這部分的營收的陳數效果
應該有在三兆到六兆
這麼樣的水準
這是第一個
我們可以看到
這部分所達到一個歷史新高
所產生出來的
這是好的
是
對 但是不好是什麼
請你去看一下這兩個相對比
2016年
這是2016年 對不起
這應該是2016年
對 2016年跟去年來相比的話
這是2025年
你去看他當時的這個
compatible bump
就是我們講的可轉債的部分
是從原來的23%到36%
一般來講發行
所謂的這個 SPO 的這種所謂可轉債
差不多是三年
三年代表就是說三年可以換成股票
但是三年期間假設你有 Touch 到你的這種轉換價
你也可以換
只是說真正的這個籌碼
或在三年以後 2026 2728 29
這時候量會出來
第二個你看私募
私募從原先的 4% 到 19%
私募也是鎖三年
所以一般來講會做私募的人
第一個他獲利可能不是太好
但是但是他是看好
未來三年的整個發展方向
所以這部分的一個籌碼
可能會在什麼時候出現
會在2020、2020、2020
會陸續籌碼會出來
因為你可以轉換成你的股票
那這部分我去算過
你用1.2兆除以現在的市值
差不多是150兆
是0.8
0.8再乘以4萬6千點的話
等於說假設我今天要趕快
要轉成所謂的股票來看的話
會影響股價的點數 400點
這個是從
第一個我們從KAPEX角度去看
Levvany會創造出的
就是那個開牌說創造出這個營收的部分
這第一個
第二個就是說
他所帶來的籌碼增加
會影響到後面的股價還有他的點數
其實也是跟最近的債券市場很像
債券市場大家不斷的供給量增加
其實根本就跟那個利率沒有關係
就是因為他不斷的發債
然後公司債的利率又比你國債的利率來的高
我變成說我的公債利率降不下來
其實這個是一個問題
這個下次有機會針對這個債券市場
我們利率我們可以來做討論
下次有機會
對
不過剛剛綜上所述
就是資本支出可能到
2020、2020、2020要注意放緩的問題
還有我們國內的籌碼
現在我們國內也是有在做資本支出
但是一樣2020、2020、2020
會是
就是剛剛我提到的combo的bump
就是它可轉換債的部分的
SPO的時間點
差不多落在那時候
所以你這時候你在看
他們敢在這時候發債
其實它創造出來的因素效果
會非常不錯
股價往上衝
可是你要小心
帶後面他的籌碼會增加
這個可能就是
他所帶來的另外一塊
就是供給量會增加
那這一塊我覺得
我要算一個公式給
給我們的這個
觀眾 好朋友 對
我覺得這個
就可以讓你知道說
現在到底有沒有泡沫
你不要再去聽這些
是好像講說
這個已經bubble或是說
一些的這種空頭總是令他去嚇你
其實我們先來看一下
其實他現在有過熱了
有過熱
你從四值處於M1跟M2
5.15跟2.25
其實是遠遠高於他的平均值
遠遠高於平均值
這個我們是40
這個我們不能否認
其實是過熱
但是你去看他的這部分的一個配洗
配洗的話 7.5兆
我用55%非常非常保守去算
其實2027年他就可以配到4.13兆
4.13兆你除以現在的市值
差不多是160兆的話
其實現在值率差不多2.8 2.5
不是太高
但是你是有這種Cash dip燈液
這部分可以拿回來
那你如果是用六成七成的話
那配合息就更高了
所以這部分的資金行情
2027年其實指數不需要看單
因為你從這樣子的獲利數字去反推
你股價越跌 你的現金值率越高
其實你的股價是越跌越便宜
你反而會刺激外資去買
所以這第一個是這樣算
然後第二個在算法上來看
到底有沒有泡沫
我們剛剛算過就是今年7.5兆
去年是4.5億兆
所以應該是66%
66%的話 你再加上M1
M1差不多是4.4
4.4再減掉
市值增加差不多是61%
其實應該是差不多增8到10%的增
就是說它現在
你的那個獲利的成長
加上M1B的成長
減掉市值的增加是增的話
代表這個產業
沒有追上
對 沒有bubble的情況
所以你用這樣角度去看
就可以很清楚就是說
其實你只要確定他的獲利數字是上去的
然後M1B現在是
1到6月是4.4%
然後我們現在市值YTD是增加61%
兩個加起來減掉
其實現在差不多在8到10附近
所以就代表說其實目前看起來
再度震驗其實沒有所謂的泡沫的問題
這個我覺得可以讓我們的觀眾
你在做你的投資其實就是選股而已
不是說他這會有所謂的這種
08年或是2000年.com
那種這種所謂泡沫的危機
等於在基本面的支撐上面
產業前景的支撐上面
資金流的支撐上面
沒有這問題
剩下就是信念跟實機點的問題
我們現在家運指數
其實以所有的全球股市來說
算厲害的也
對 其實它若是以這個
它的這一次7月份的股災
其實集中市場它比OTC要來得強
那因為集中市場有一個
護國省山災的地方
所以它蝶幅算是
比這個其他三個市場要來的稍微
稍微可控一些
那我們從P Ratio來看
我們用未來的這個
Forewater EPS去估的話
其他的P Ratio有17.4倍
那這個費半是21.2
日本是20%
日本這麼高
對 22倍 對
你如果是用這樣來看
其實台股在這個地方
用Forewater EPS去估他的
P Ratio其實算是
算上的Value
但你會對照過來看說
怎麼會有一個這個
5.2的
你去看一下上半年的這個三星跟
海翼式的財報
我把換成台幣
台灣剛剛是3.8兆
你知道他上半年
他這兩家公司
單單賺台幣賺多少
5.8兆
他賺5.8兆
所以5.8兆你去PK一個
我們全市場賺3.8兆
一樣上半年他只有兩家公司
直接完勝你全部1980
家的上次各位公司的獲利數值
為什麼北比這麼低
因為大家現在還是不認同
記憶體它是一個成長股
假設它是成長股
它是用這種所謂的方具的角度來看
其實現在的
現在6000點的寒股其實非常便宜
但是目前看起來大家現在扭轉這樣的
格局就是它現在簽一個叫LTA
叫Longton的這部分的這個規障
它把長約簽下去之後
綁量在綁架的過程裡面
其實它這部分會慢慢的回升上來
我們認為說這兩個市場
應該在三利裡面
他佔領非常非常有角色
哪三利 算利 存利跟電利
台灣這三利都有
他只有存利 他只有儲存利
所以他差不多佔25%左右
那台灣是三利全部囊括
所以台灣全拿的情況之下
他的PVRation其實是Undervalue
但是你後面還是要觀察
這個市場再跌下去也不對
也不能太看稅他
因為他去槓桿完之後
他回歸基本面
其實應該是有走他的基本面的路才對
他也不能太弱
因為這一波的去港感風暴
就是從韓國開始的
沒錯 沒錯
他們的本應比是跟著三星海力數
我們本應比跟著台積電
所以自然我們會稍微高一些
但還是你覺得低於正常的價值
我覺得是 undervalued
因為我目前看起來
以這個QQ的報價上來看
我們講說四大的存力
HBM
還有這個 DDR4 DDR5
還有LP DDR部分
Nanfresh SSD的部分
其實這四個Hannis都有
而且他獲利數字真的非常好
那我們覺得說後面他應該是有機會回歸基本面
只是說現在開槓桿是開得有點大
當然這一波去槓桿希望
有人說已經去了95%
但是我們先不管點數
有時候點數不見得反映在我們的股票的個股上
但是展望2027剛剛聽起來
其實眾多條件的聚集是沒有大問題的
就要注意機會跟風險在哪裡
沒錯 我想在10個條件
10個利好跟10個利空
反正現在足球進入下半場
你剩下下半場這五個月
你要去檢視這一波
假設任何的這個回檔下來
你就看這個部分的利多跟利好
有沒有所變化
我們先看利多的部分
A讓我們辦法全面變現
兌現
其實現在AI進入第三個軸期
第一個軸期叫做算力軸期
晶片軸期就是算力軸期
第二軸期我們把它叫做基建軸期
就是基礎建設的軸期
第三個叫做信用軸期
其實現在進入信用軸期
你未來誰能夠拿到最多的便宜的錢
誰就會是贏家
其實這一次為什麼揮達他能夠這樣子的
去做這個所謂的這個
融資的這部分的擔保人
其實因為他賺得撥滿盆滿
他是唯一能夠發動這一波AI裡面
最主要的一個角色
那我覺得這個全面兌現
就是我們剛剛一開始提到
為什麼我們從這樣的邏輯下來看
就是從剛剛的我們講的
現金流的部分
然後到營收站他的資本支付計畫的筆的部分
然後再去用阿普茲的這部分的一個算法
去算出他合理的營收應該多少
那這部分我覺得要全面兌現
這就用這樣來觀察
然後台積電的這部分的獲利數字
我覺得台積電是一個非常
我們講說透明度很高的一個公司
其實很好估
那我們覺得他的營收QOQ
每一個月其實我們估起來都還滿順的
所以目前看起來應該持續高成長
然後台灣GDP已經不用講了
因為我們已經把2026的第三第四季
跟2027年1234季的
單季的GDP都告訴你
主技術他講得非常清楚
今年11點多 明年6點多
然後明年是先下後上
今年是先上後下
所以這個部分我覺得是持續高層長
第六率我覺得是重點
我覺得現在大家有一個誤解就是
常常寶 挖許當作是一個鷹派
不是嗎
我這樣子看
我自己內部看吧
我覺得今年最差最差就是
不升不降
好一點應該要降起
為什麼
因為你去看他今年稻崎的戰券有十早
然後今年稻崎的戰券有十早
戒心環就的過程裡面
他利率再往上升的話
其實他的這個戰券
他的這個所謂的財政資質
會大幅的增加
所以我們覺得第一個
他是沒有這樣的一個條件
第二個就是說
你去看他的Finnip曲線兩條線
包括Infraction跟他的job report的部分
目前看起來已經soft
已經轉下來
所以目前看起來
我覺得他是比較沒有這樣的一個條件
去做所謂的升息的動作
那不升息那頂多就是變
on change 那 on change的話
假設他的這部分兩個數字有稍微下來的話
可能他這部分還要再做一些降息
好 因為這邊的觀察當然是
我們都知道
川普或者是說英文國的財政來說
絕對是希望降息
但是瓦許他可能要維持一個檯面上
在通紅抗爭上面的一個立場
沒錯 所以他就變成說他回到
回到他的這個論調裡面
叫mermer指數嘛
事先上次有來講
就是說他
講話越少的這部分的聯準會主席
其實波動是比較低的
我覺得他有點失成當時葉倫的這樣一個情況
那台幣的部分我覺得31.24年線
他只要能夠升破的話
這波行情應該是不容小序
但是因根果是外資買超台幣升值
不是台幣升值外資買超
因果要先搞清楚
所以這個台幣升值部分
就要看外資買賣超
因為目前看起來
E2對M1.4兆
所以這是事實
所以台幣要持續升值
ETF我覺得要聊一下就是
ETF我覺得會是後面的
主要的一個雪球效應
現在的ETF到10.17兆
那其中有7.5兆是被動式的
主動式是8800億
然後另外傳統式的mute flow
放是1.78兆加起來10兆
我去算一下9到12月份
預計發行的這部分的基金有
4000到5000億
所以這部分應該是有機會再捲進來
然後散戶全部回歸是看
融資維持率
現在融資維持率有回到200
當初48218的當時的
維持綠是在208
那假設他這個部分又回到208以上
其實這個部分的這個
這種所謂的氣氛上來看
我覺得就是比較不錯的
那這個部分就是
其他就是地緣政治
這邊可以做參考
那這個部分可能就是比較負面
要留意
ETF採踏
這可能要小心再來一次
我們上次也有討論過這件事
可是這是還好
還好 對
因為我覺得
台灣的股民其實比
比韓國股股比
其實
我們有經驗
數值比
我們是
我們有經驗
現役成變數值比較強
那這個就是
評價了
台股市值的這部分泡沫
現在差不多400多
那我們就要去看說到底
現在的這個市值
我們假如到160兆的話
台股就公共5萬點
是
對 現在是150
我現在講集中市場
所以這幾個我覺得就是
把它當作是
你在這一波
有任何的回檔
你就把它拿出來看一下
到底有沒有打勾
有打勾 那你就要稍微去做一些
檢詞你這部分的一個部位
那最後的話 因為拜你們剛剛封部完
我們用很快速的幫大家
review一下這個第四季的投資策略
或者是說整個半年報告的成績
光哥總點評一下
我想在整個數字上來看
我們一直對這個EPS的這部分預測
跟獲利的Eni的預測
其實我們非常非常的注重
所以在整體來看
你去看這一次的這個
上半年的這部分財報3.65兆
成長116%將近
那其中比較好的就是這兩個
一個是半導體
一個是金融
金融業喔
其實金融業我其實是蠻看好
因為其實大家把金融業
當作是傳統產業其實不對
其實金融業也是AI
因為你去類AI的部分
就是說它事實上是跟AI
是綁在一起的
不管它投資部門
它有投資AI的這部分的股票
或者是說它跟它企業
這部分的生意往來也有跟AI
其實它算是一個AI
等於說它是雨露均沾
只是說它是比較末端
所以在這一次的這個獲利數字來看的話
其實它的這個成長幅度是蠻大的
所以我覺得在這兩塊
我們是覺得在
懸股上面來看
可以這個肋骨來看
那另外一個懸股方式
我是從這個角度來看
我覺得這蠻有趣的
就是股價
我們去把1000塊錢以上的50檔
好 1000塊以上 50千金
那另外就是100到500人
這兩個我們是比較看好
主要原因是你看這兩個
這兩個的這個
最後的YY
是
成長幅度最大
一個是661 182
其實我們在買股票的時候
不是越便宜越好
其實現在
這個AI的產業
進入了一個本益比沒有風頂的概念
我記得以前我師父告訴我說
你要買turn around the story的股票
其實就是本益比沒有風頂
本益比沒有風頂
意思就是說你把PE ratio
再處以它的成長率
假設我現在PE是50倍
我成長率是100%
那我現在是0.3
就是說用這樣的沒有超過1以上
其實這個都算是合理
所以如果是以這樣這兩個類股上來看
他加權的平均的EPS是92.7
千元以上的
然後這個100到543
然後他的P-Rex其實100到500
其實是P-Rex蠻低的
等於說他是有機會
去成為未來的千金股
所以你在這樣的邏輯去看
你就是把財報整理完過後
然後再回過頭來
你去看一下他的孤子
尤其孤子在整個投資上面來看
是投資人最大的盲點
那你可能會買比較
你會覺得
因為我們常常碰到我們的客戶
會告訴我說
我現在是傳統產業
為什麼我的股價漲不上來
我的PG才15倍
那因為你沒有AI
就變成說有這樣子的一個情況
所以目前把這樣子的一個邏輯
跟各位觀眾好朋友做分享
我覺得應該就可以做一些選股
好 前緣以上當然應該是法人盤
對不對
但是很令人驚喜的是
100塊到500塊錢的這一組
極具潛力
就像我們之前講說
有一些ETF在挑的時候
他不會挑台灣50了
他會挑可能前150裡面
有機會擊定台灣50的
就是這樣的一個概念
光哥給我們很新的一些
啟發跟思考
今天非常謝謝光哥
我們現在要接下來做的事情
就請大家打開手上的股價圖
誰是100塊到500塊
就明明光哥講了那麼多
然後我們就回到說到底誰是這一組
可是要搭配的就是
獲利年齡的
還有所謂的
所謂的PR
就是本一層當地的一個狀況